well evictions are expected to increase
the cdc more the cdc moratorium expired
on saturday
experts say the one of the worst things
a tenant can do is ignore the eviction
notice
the i-team's vanessa murphy is live in
downtown las vegas
outside the regional justice center with
more on the help available for tenants
facing eviction vanessa
this is the first business day since the
moratorium on evictions
expired now eviction notices are
expected to be delivered and
lockouts can even begin today if the
landlords
started that process during the
moratorium now
the self-help center here is someplace
that both
tenants and landlords can go for help
what you found today it's going to pause
it
technically they can come out
on the 4th to lock the doors and
tomorrow
i think you're going to be ok the civil
law help center at the regional justice
center is anticipating such an
uptick in evictions staff and space have
been added
there are thousands of people out there
who are just really worried about
how they're going to make up for past
due rent
and where they're going to live and i
would call that a crisis
lauren pena is the directing attorney in
nevada we have what's called the summary
eviction process which is one of the
fastest in the country
so it is rapid fire lightning speed
she says tenants with an eviction notice
should file an answer with the court
within
seven business days apply for rental
assistance
and choose mediation if you don't do
that
that eighth day you could get locked out
the legal aid center of southern nevada
which oversees the help center
reports assisting 3 200 tenants in a
typical month
in june that number jumped to 7 thousand
now that the cdc eviction moratorium
expired
saturday another increase is expected i
haven't been working i haven't been
paying everything
and i'm going to be basically out tommy
wesley tells the i-team his rent
jumped from 575 a month to 8.50
he showed us this online portal he says
he just doesn't have the money
he hasn't received an eviction notice
yet but he's worried he will and he's
here learning about his
options i've never been through anything
like this before so i don't really know
how we'll go
hopefully it gives me a little time to
try to figure something out
i talked with the manager of tommy's
property he tells me
yes rent is going up he says tenants did
receive
notice and that costs have gone up for
landlords
he also tells me for tenants willing to
work together
he will consider giving them another
month
of rent at their old rate so hopefully
tommy is watching right now
we have some helpful links for our
viewers on our website at 8newsnow.com
reporting live in downtown las vegas
vanessa murphy
8 news now